in the wake of the Nashville shooting of
Christian children by a transgender
identifying killer the White House is
doubling down on its defense of
transgenderism and is now insinuating
that if you don't support transiting the
kids you are actually guilty of killing
kids
I know that these political attacks can
really take toll on people's mental
health so I want to say directly to
lgbtqi plus kids you are loved Just As
You Are
just the way you are and if you're
feeling overwhelmed you call 988 the
national crisis hotline and dial the
number three to talk to a counselor who
has been specifically trained to support
lgbtqi plus kids this is a new service
that the Biden Administration is proud
to offer during these incredibly hard
times for these trans kids
the White House is telling young people
to call them and then the Liberals will
give these young people their views on
lgbtism and and tell the little boys
that they're little girls and little
girls that they're little boys but maybe
it's got decent intentions right the
White House at least is right to be
concerned about the spike in the teen
suicide rate teen suicide has jumped 29
over the past decade
coincidentally though that is precisely
the same period during which our culture
and law began to affirm transgenderism
also coincidentally as the culture and
law affirmed transgenderism transgender
identity among the youth skyrocketed
young people teenagers and young adults
now identify as transgender at more than
twice almost three times the rate of all
U.S adults and I know that correlation
does not imply causation but it does
raise a question
is it possible that all this transgender
affirmation is having the opposite
effect that we're told it does
is it possible that transgender
affirmation far from alleviating
depression and suicidality is actually
exacerbating those problems
the first rule of Medicine
is first to do no harm
if these two novel Trends transgenderism
and teen suicide Spikes have been
overlapping almost perfectly
is it possible that those two things
might have something to do with one
another is it possible that the true
cause of the spike in these particular
deaths the spike that liberals
histrionically have been calling a
genocide is it possible that the driver
of those deaths is not transphobia but
transgenderism itself I'm Michael knows
it's the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the show we've got a lot
coming up huge news today Jack Daniels
has gone trans yes
on the heels of Bud Light going trans
actly gone trans it's gone drag but a
lot of conservatives are complaining
about this I'm I'm not complaining
actually I'm reserving my ire here we'll
get to why in just a moment
first though the Biden Administration
cannot win for losing everything that
Joe Biden touches turns to Ash and even
the liberal press is noticing it
on the this was Thursday night
Thursday late afternoon there was a news
dump and the News dump was that the
Afghanistan withdrawal report is finally
coming out this is now long overdue and
even Ed O'Keefe at CBS News not exactly
a right-wing Outlet called out John
Kirby over at the White House and said
wait a second why why are you dumping
this report right before Good Friday
right before everyone's taking time off
for Easter this this is you're obviously
just trying to hide this
so John thank you for doing this but I
think I speak on behalf of my colleagues
in this room and we want the record to
reflect this was sent to us about 10
minutes before the briefing began with
little notice and it's the very
definition of a modern major holiday
News company releasing this uh at the
beginning of the high holidays and after
months of requests from Republicans and
the broader public
um so why today and is this all we get
and is this a response to the studies
that were done by the agencies or is
this considered a summary so good on Ed
O'Keefe for calling him out like this it
obviously is a major holiday news dump
and why are they doing it it's because
the Afghanistan withdrawal was a
complete debacle it was tragic and a
huge embarrassment for the Biden
Administration and so the only option
they've got is to sweep it under the rug
that is their best bet there's no other
way yes it's embarrassing that they're
being called out for for the holiday
news dump but it's less embarrassing
than having to actually answer for this
the Biden foreign policy has been a
complete disaster and we've just heard
about this from Russia Russia is now
saying that that the U.S is in a hot war
with Russia not a cold war not a new
Cold War not a proxy war through Ukraine
Russia's saying we're in a hot warp they
say quote
I think we've already passed the period
of Cold War now we are in the phase of a
hot conflict with the United States we
are witnessing the direct involvement of
that country in a hybrid war with Russia
on various fronts
the way our American opponents are
recklessly provocatively and in many
respects absolutely carelessly moving up
the escalation ladder the way they are
blinded by their absolute absolutely
absurd certainty about their ability to
inflict a strategic defeat on Russia
makes one doubt they're mental faculties
and their Common Sense I've told you
before I'll say it again the best kind
of propaganda is the kind that's true
and is this propaganda yes and is it
true yes it is also I am seriously
doubting the mental faculties and common
sense of my leaders here in the United
States obviously our president barely
knows his own name and you want to talk
about their common sense they don't know
the difference between boys and girls
and men and women and as pertains to
this issue are sclerotic Elite is
sleepwalking us into World War III
show me the lie here show me the lie
that we're in an increasingly hot war
with Russia
we are
yeah that's true it's not a war that the
American people seem very much to want
but it's a war that was forced upon us
and it's been building for a very long
time
and it would be one thing if we had an
agile intelligent serious Elite that was
running the country that was waging this
war but we don't we have Joe Biden who
doesn't know what day it is we've got
Mark milley who wants to focus on white
rage and critical race theory for his
poor troops we've got we've got the
Admiral Levine assistant Secretary of
Health who says we need to trans the
kids we've got John Kirby over there a
spokesman who who is trying to cover up
all the failures of the Afghanistan
withdrawal from the political class it's
just a complete joke and by the way
we've got Vladimir zielinski the leader
of Ukraine who says that Joe Biden
essentially caused the war is Joe Biden
pulled the pressure off of Russia in the
form of lifting those sanctions before
he reinstituted the sanctions and
because Joe Biden literally invited
Putin to invade part of Ukraine he said
if it's only a minor incursion into
Ukraine then it won't be that big of a
deal
and so what does Putin do he invades
Ukraine and now what's happening we're
just escalating this war mindlessly and
mindlessly
he's saying this is
this is increasing by the day and it is
Wars have started over a lot less hot
Wars have started over a lot less I'd
love to the Russia points out says the
Absurd certainty about America's ability
to inflict a strategic defeat on Russia
it increasingly seems like an absurd
certainty because we were told that
those those sanctions were going to
Rally the whole world we're going to
impose those sanctions on Russia who's
going to destroy the U.S economy and
what happened it basically boomeranged
back on the United States and Europe
especially Europe but it hit back on the
west
we didn't Russia we didn't end
the war it didn't work
I don't consider that a knock on the U.S
and I don't consider that something to
be admired about Russia but it sure as
hell a knock on our Elite these guys
don't know what they're doing
and now we're trusting them to what to
talk us down from World War III no way
they're going to get us into World War
III if we're not in it already and then
do you trust them to wage World War III
I don't I don't trust Joe Biden to go
buy the right ice ice cream down the
street
I don't trust him to do anything and I
don't trust his people to do anything
either you know I trust I trust you we
should talk about it when you want to
talk you got to check out pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Knowles prices of essential goods
are not coming down anytime soon you
need to start looking at ways to cut
costs one of the ways you can do that is
by making the switch to Pure Talk Pure
Talk saves the average family over 900
per year you can get the same coverage
you're used to at half the rate you're
currently paying not only will you save
money but you will also get the
satisfaction of knowing you are
supporting a great American company the
CEO and chairman of pure talk is a U.S
military veteran when you become a Pure
Talk customer you are given the option
to support America's Warrior partnership
which is an organization that works to
prevent veteran suicide with a range of
affordable plans to choose from you can
find the perfect option for your needs
get unlimited talk text and plenty of
data for just thirty dollars a month
with no contract
switch over to puretalk in as little as
10 minutes while keeping your phone in
your phone number their us-based
customer service team makes the switch
super easy go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Knowles Canada wlas save
fifty percent five zero off your first
month that is puretalk.com promo code
Knowles Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless
now Biden is completely collapsing and
so there's someone in the wings
waiting to take that Democrat nomination
for president in 2024 away from him that
person would be Governor Bateman himself
the American Psycho of California
governor Gavin Newsom
Governor Newsom is on a nationwide tour
why is he on a nationwide tour I don't
know he just decides he wants to see the
country you know pack up the RV yeah
maybe he's on a nationwide tour it just
coincidentally happens to take him to
Florida
and then he's speaking at new College of
Florida that is the college that
DeSantis has gone after to impose a more
serious curriculum onto
so you can't teach the crazy woke stuff
anymore so Gavin Newsom is taking his
fight against what he calls
authoritarian leaders to Ron desantis's
backyard and he's going to visit the new
school because Ron DeSantis gutted the
diversity Office of the new school and
they're trying to have the new school
teach kids things that are real
and DeSantis is there to stick it to or
rather Newsom is there to stick it
around DeSantis what does this tell us
tells us a few things one tells us the
word authoritarian doesn't mean anything
as I've said for a very long time
authoritarian is just when your
political opponents do something that
you don't like so that's authoritarian
you're wielding your political Authority
right that's what politics is it's about
wielding Authority and when you wield
your political Authority you say that's
just and wonderful and open-minded and
when your opponent wields this political
Authority that's awful and authoritarian
so that's a meaningless word the other
thing that
Newsome is showing us here is that he's
running for president whether he's
declared or not he is at this moment
running for president he's setting the
stage for a campaign but the third thing
he's showing us is he's not running for
president against Joe Biden and he's not
running for president against Donald
Trump he's running against Ron DeSantis
this is the shadow campaign for
president
the
surface level campaign for president is
Biden versus Trump
but the shadow campaign is
Newsome versus DeSantis Newsom thinks
that DeSantis is going to be the nominee
he's not taking the fight to Trump he's
taking it to DeSantis
and it could be Biden and Donald Trump
are relatively up there in age Trump
seems like a young vibrant man Biden
does not but there's still both a little
bit long in the tooth and the libs are
trying to lock up Trump in three
different places they'll try to get them
in New York they'll try to get him in DC
they'll try to get him in Georgia and so
this is the shadow campaign and we're
still so far out that it could happen
and so Newsom he's running against
authoritarianism now speaking of
Newsome and authoritarianism he's got a
bill that he's pushing in California the
bill would upend the tradition of
locally controlled schools so what the
bill would say is that local school
districts do not have the right to
kick the woke stuff out of their
curricula
the local school districts can't do that
because the state is going to usurp that
power and the state the state of
California is going to enforce
woke lessons critical race Theory the
weird sex stuff all of it in the
curricula
this is as anti-freedom As It Gets
this is as authoritarian whatever that
means as it gets but what the Liberals
would say is no no we're we're defending
Freedom we're defending the freedom
to trans the kids
and with the conservatives it says no no
we're defending the political freedom of
local communities and taxpayers and
parents to set the curricula in their
schools and the way that their kids are
raised
but they're both conceptions of freedom
everybody thinks he's fighting for
Freedom every single person Communists
think they're fighting for freedom
totalitarians think they're fighting for
freedom
Libertarians conservatives traditional
everybody thinks they're fighting for
freedom
freedom is contingent on one's
understanding of the good
that's what it's all about and that's
why I think a lot of the political
debates over Freedom no your
anti-freedom no I'm pro-freedom you're
an authoritarian all that stuff it's
just silly it misses the point because
what Freedom means is contingent on how
one conceives of the good
that's why political debates ultimately
have to come down to questions of virtue
they ultimately have to come down to
questions of what is good what is bad
who are we why are we here what are we
after what's the point of human life
what do we worship what do we serve
that's what it comes down to
and the liberal conception of freedom is
not Liberty
traditionally understood the liberal
conception of freedom is licentiousness
it's the freedom to do weird sex stuff
it's the freedom to do drugs it's the
freedom to loaf around it's the free
it's the freedom to daydream and have
delusions and the right-wing conception
of freedom is the freedom to do what we
ought to do and the freedom to have a
thriving political community and the
freedom to make decisions about how your
community is going to run through
self-government through school boards
through setting curricula that's
that's the right wing it's they're two
totally different conceptions of freedom
one of them happens to be a correct
sense of freedom
but but they're all going to claim that
and so enough about the piffle of well
you're a liberal no you're a liberal no
you're authoritarian no it's just what
is good what do we want to do how do we
get along together how do we do good and
avoid evil the basic charge of any
society and of any individual now
speaking of changing conceptions of the
good
Disney Disney
they did it again Disney is changing the
lyrics to The Little Mermaid
specifically the song Kiss the Girl now
I have not seen The Little Mermaid since
I was about five years old
I don't remember anything about it
really and I've never read the Hans
Christian Anderson book so I
all I remember really is that song you
got to kiss the girl I don't even really
remember the tune goes so go on and kiss
the girl you know that song so that's
the song They're Gonna Change
and why you know why they're going to
change it
you're not allowed to just kiss a girl
anymore
you're practically a rapist if you K if
you kiss a girl if you like a girl and
you're kind of flirting with each other
and then you lean in you know in a
little have a little smooch oh yeah so
you're not allowed to do that you need
to get written and notarized letter of
consent from her witnessed by three
different people signed off on by a
judge that's the then maybe you can
consider sending her a telegram to ask
if she might be willing to kiss you what
are the lyrics these are the lyrics
they're going to change
yes you want her
look at her you know you do possible she
wants you to there is one way to ask her
it don't take a word not a single word
go on and kiss the girl this is this is
an even sillier version of the left-wing
temper tantrums over maybe it's cold
outside
they say oh it's not consensual it's
rapey it's coercive it's
no it's romantic it's romantic to go off
when you're you go up and you're
flirting with the girl and you both kind
of like each other and you both kind of
lean in a little bit and then what are
you doing you Smooch
and she's like oh she likes to kiss you
or you know what maybe she doesn't like
you to kiss her and so she turns her
head away
and then smooch lands on the cheek and
you got rejected okay all right there
you go at least you tried to kiss the
girl the libs
have lost a sense of romance
that's why they don't get
kiss the girl that's why they don't get
maybe it's cold outside the whole point
of maybe it's cold outside it's like oh
I really shouldn't stay but maybe it's
cold outside all right well maybe okay
I'll just stay for a little bit I guess
it's a little game of Seduction it's a
game of flirtation it's it's that the
woman because she has an ideal of
modesty she wants to stay with the guy
but she knows that she ought to be
modest and so there's a there's a dance
that's taking place there and there's a
much more innocent version of that even
taking place in
the Disney song but the libs have lost
that because they've lost the conception
of the difference between men and women
for the libs everybody is the same for
the libs everybody's just
we're all just kind of
blobs we're all sexless blobs
and so you gotta this started with
feminism but you that means you you
can't treat male female reactions as
something special and fun and
croquettish and no no it's just we're
all just blob so you should treat your
romantic partner in the same way you
treat your accountant it's completely
ridiculous and and you see the the
height of this in
yesterday's great International holiday
it was International asexuality day did
you know that asexuality which literally
means you're just not sexual
but then I saw a meme going around
they're all like these explainer memes
from the sexual Revolution and this one
it's an asexual myths here are the myths
all asexuals hate and don't want sex
and the correction is not all asexuals
feel this way okay
uh myth asexuals don't want to be in
relationships response many do
with or without sex
so not even just without sex with or
with that asexuality is a choice someone
says no you're thinking of celibacy or
abstinence we can't stop being asexual
but asexual means what does it mean it
means you either like sex or you don't
like sex and you do want to be in a
relationship or you don't want to be in
a relationship and if you are in a
relationship it's either with sex or
without sex and that's asexuality uh
no that's just anything
it's just that's just every option
so on asexuality Day we celebrate
it everything but it's supposed to be
really Niche and special
and the problem that the libs are
running into and the reason that there
are gazillion genders and the reason
that we can't pin down the meaning of
any particular concept anymore is
because
if everything means everything then
nothing means anything
nothing means anything if anybody can be
a woman then
woman doesn't mean anything
if anybody can be an American American
doesn't mean anything
if any if anybody can be asexual then
asexual asexual actually does not does
not mean anything now speaking of
matters of the Boudoir I would strongly
recommend you check out Helix sleep
right now go to helixsleep.com Knowles
after a long day at work why are you
sacrificing a good night's sleep with a
terrible mattress you need to check out
Helix mattress Helix is a premium
mattress brand that provides tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences the Helix lineup includes 14
unique mattresses including a collection
of luxury models a mattress for Big and
Tall sleepers even a mattress made just
for kids I've had my Helix mattress for
almost three years now I absolutely
adore it you're nervous about buying a
mattress online okay you don't have to
be Helix has a sleep quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress because why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
get out of my mattress I'm a married man
go to helixsleep.com Knowles take the
two minute quiz find the perfect
mattress for your body and sleep type
your mattress will come right to your
door for free plus your Alex has a 10
year warranty and you get to try that
for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you totally will love
it Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners hurry over to helixsleep.com
Knowles with Helix better sleep starts
now
my favorite comment yesterday is from
ASMR conservative who says the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again and expecting
a different outcome an alternate
definition is Democrat
a little bit of an on the nose joke just
like boom owned Democrats owned you Libs
but you make a good point
why is it that the libs are screwing up
everything
why is it that the libs are causing
Internal Affairs to collapse Foreign
Affairs to collapse their their policies
and their ideologies are driving up
rates of depression and anxiety and
suicide why is it that why is it that
the libs are failing on every front
well it's because they have the wrong
idea it's because they view the world in
a way that's wrong and so actually
that's to be expected what would be
weirder is if they were right about some
things but wrong about other things if
they were good at certain things and bad
at other things
that I wouldn't know how to make sense
of but the fact that they're just
terrible at everything
and that everything the Biden
Administration touches turns to Ash that
makes sense to me
because he's wrong his view of the world
is just fundamentally wrong
and I don't even think he has a view of
the world but but his
political party and the political
movement he's part of where the winds
are blowing
they're just wrong about everything
they're wrong about the nature of man
they're wrong about the purpose of life
on Earth
they're wrong about what the nation is
they're wrong about
babies they're wrong about foreign
policy just wrong
so if they're wrong then everything is
going to fall apart and they're going to
keep doing the same thing and hope to
get a different result which is not a
very wise thing to do
now
we have got some really big breaking
news the really big breaking news of
course is that
Jack Daniels has gone drag
this right after Bud Light was caught
sponsoring a transvestite Dylan Mulvaney
a lot of pushback against this well Jack
Daniels a while ago I guess sponsored
this drag campaign people have dug that
up and now they're giving Jack the old
Bud Light treatment
listen people we have a party to plan
and we need to go get some decorations
yeah we need to get this going and we're
expecting people oh my God she looks so
stunning in everything
[Music]
we should make a jack fire cranberry
yeah Jack fire cranberry
fill a lowball glass with ice you have
one and a half ounces of Jack fire and
four ounces of cranberry juice
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you get the idea it goes on
for a little while now
everyone's criticizing Jack Daniels
especially on the right
I however don't have a huge problem with
this
I don't have a huge problem I had a huge
problem with Bud Light I have less of a
huge problem with this because
it's not that Jack is advertising their
regular Jack Daniels here it's not good
old number seven okay it's not that Jack
is advertising their Gentleman Jack
their higher end whiskey you saw the
specific product that they are
advertising here is Jack fire it's their
ripoff of Fireball cinnamon flavored
whiskey
and
100 of the people who drink Jack fire
are at least homosexuals at least they
might be trans they might be drag queens
they might it's a not it's not a never
it's not a heterosexual beverage I don't
even think women really drink it I think
if women are going to drink take a shot
of one of these kind of frou-frou
cinnamon things they'll probably just
drink Fireball Jack has that bite to it
it's more of a man's drink albeit a man
who's a little bit light in his
Lynchburg loafers so in this case you
have Jack Daniels marketing a fopish
drink to a foppish crowd of people
all right that's it fair enough right
that's not that doesn't offend me
what it what offends me is when Bud
Light
markets a drink that is only consumed by
frat stars and construction workers and
dudes at baseball games
and markets that to transvestites who
actually claim to be women and who
who dance around and make awful
caricatures of women all the time that
bugs me that that's a real finger in the
eye of the customer base of Bud Light
but for Jack that's okay I don't mind so
as long as I don't do it told number
seven I don't really that's okay that's
fine it fits it fits I don't mind when
weird cultural movements
are at least coherent or semi-coherent
what bothers me is when the
LGBT gay stapo just tries to colonize
everything else and they try to go in
and take normal products you know sports
bras from Nike and then put them on this
dude and say you know just do it no I
don't want to do that I don't do that
or when
drag queens go in and they start
jiggling for Elementary School students
drag queens if you're gonna have a drag
queen show that belongs in a weird part
of town and some weird kind of CD
Cabaret late at night with a guy
checking IDs at the door if you're gonna
have it at all it certainly doesn't
belong
in
elementary schools
that's the real that's the real issue
here
speaking of vopish fellows
and turning to 2016 as well the libs are
having a meltdown the libs are just so
so angry they're addicted to Trump they
can't quit him but they're so angry at
him they're scarred by him Chris Hayes
over on MSNBC
he's giving his analysis of what
Republicans should be doing vis-a-vis
Trump after having been scarred in 2016.
there are lots of people who have
watched politics closely who've got a
lot of anxiety stemming from that 2016
election and probably will for as long
as they live I know I will everywhere
you look the signs point to the fact
that Donald Trump is incredibly
unpopular with persuadable voters
outside the Republican base
freaked out so permanently scarred by
2016 that obvious truth is often
obscured
and the truth is that Donald Trump
Listen to Me Now does not possess a
magic power that turns political gravity
upside down
he is an unlikable figure who lots of
persuadable Voters find repulsive at
some point
Republicans are going to have to face
this reality the guy's utterly toxic
as long as you keep supporting him
you're going to lose a lot of winnable
elections Donald Trump is so terrible
and everyone hates him and you better
not run him for
him says Chris Hayes the big lab on the
big lib Network don't do it Republicans
why won't you listen to me Trump is
terrible and he's awful and you're gonna
lose if you don't do what I say get rid
of trump
I hate him so much
I don't know he's kind of convincing me
that Trump's the guy
if if MSNBC
out of such concern for the Republican
party's electoral viability
MSNBC says look we really have your best
interests at heart Republicans I really
look I want Republicans to win elections
I know I'm a lifelong Democrat and my
whole network exists just to get
Republicans out of elected life but I'm
look I'm taking a break from that I'm
really concerned for you I'm just
telling you you'd be crazy to nominate
that guy Trump he's he's a he's so easy
to beat that guy is so easy to beat for
president that we're trying to arrest
him in three different locales in
America to keep him from campaigning yo
because he's so easy you know you get
him out there and the more people see of
trump the more they're going to hate his
guts that's why we're doing everything
we can to shut him up and keep him off
the campaign Trail and ideally just put
him behind bars
right does that make sense to you
it doesn't make sense to me I don't know
and the the permanent scarring that's
the key too
the key is
that the political class which is mostly
liberal But it includes some squishes in
establishment Republican types
it was Unthinkable to them
that Trump could be elected
it was Unthinkable it was traumatizing
to them
because
the options for America
we've got the far left over here
we got the center left over here the
options were supposed to be between
those two poles
and that was it and it's okay and
sometimes sometimes you get a bush and
sometimes you get a Clinton but you know
it's a well and we'll complain about it
but you know those are the options and
then when you had someone come in and
say actually no you guys are wrong on
trade you're wrong on foreign policy
you're wrong on abortion you're wrong on
manufacturing you're wrong on all of it
that was that that short-circuited the
liberal class
I'm not saying Trump can win in 2024
they might just say nope we're not going
to let you win even if even if 80 of the
people vote for you we're not going to
let you win again but
it does show you the real threat that
guy posed how many years later are we
seven years later they still can't get
this man out of their head he haunts
their dreams we're coming up in almost
one year since the release of my buddy
Matt Walsh's groundbreaking documentary
what is a woman which exposed radical
gender ideology for what it is you'd
think this would be ample time for
people to come up with an answer to the
question
you would be wrong as Matt discovered at
the yaf Q a in New Mexico just a few
nights ago their answers to the question
are still just as confusing and
nonsensical they don't they don't have
answers I saw I saw this clip from Matt
I said to Elise I said didn't
shouldn't they have thought of an answer
the movie came out over a year ago
there's this Great Clip going around for
Matt's speech where a self-identified
trans woman meaning a dude attempted to
answer that simple question what is a
woman here is what that person responded
quote a woman is somebody who is
included and respected and seen and
participates in society and recognized
by other women uh-huh
uh what hmm if you haven't seen what is
a woman or if you're on the left and
somehow still find yourself confused by
biology I've got great news you can now
get 30 off your daily wire Plus
Membership when you use the code woman
if you've already seen the film then you
understand how important it is if you
haven't or know someone who hasn't seen
it tell them to watch it we need to
start recruiting more people back to the
side of truth and reality to watch what
is a woman join now dailywire.com
subscribe and use code woman to save 30
off your membership
and here we go baby my favorite time of
the week when I get to hear from you in
the mailbag the mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter code nulls kwles to get 50
off your first month take it away
with the voicemail back
hey Michael I'm a UMass Lowell student
wondering how I should go about dating
in college on a woke campus by the way
she totally come to this campus it would
be great but back to the question I have
tried going to the Catholic groups I've
tried the churches and the closest I had
was a girl who quoted The Serpent and
then stalked me for like three months so
that wasn't exactly the best experience
and I am still trying with little to no
success so I'm wondering what advice do
you have thank you and good day
I don't know that you can
I'm not saying don't try
I mean College there's a time and a
place for everything in that place is
college as some derelicts people
sometimes say
but
when I was in college
I was still an atheist and derelict and
you know I I wasn't dating to get
married in college
uh and so there were ample opportunities
to you know meet lots of lovely gals but
the culture when I was in college which
was now 10 years ago it was a hookup
culture it was unusual for people to
date seriously and it's I don't think
anyone even really liked that fact they
just that's just what the culture was
and it's only gotten worse I talked to
kids on campuses all around the country
and they say oh yeah we're in talking
phases and you can't you're not even
really allowed to ask are we dating and
are we serious are we going steady can I
can I put my pin on you I don't know can
we go up to Lover's point in my old
Chevrolet and neck I'm just using lines
from Happy Days at this point so
I don't know I don't want to give you
false hope
now I think you probably can you're
listening to this show so you're
obviously intelligent you're obviously
wise beyond your years you're probably a
good looking man so you can I think a
little bit of confidence is helpful
because on the one hand if you
participate in the hookup culture there
will be an aspect of social proof that
will convince other women to be
attracted to you that's
how our animal animalistic kind of
psychology works but if you're the
strong silent type who says no I don't
want to get in into that kind of
nonsense I want to do the real thing
that will attract a different kind of
woman to you and a better woman actually
so
I would just be patient I would just end
and if you look around and say wow I'm
in a degenerate hookup culture where the
Pickens are a little bit slim around
here that might just be the fact okay
and you might have to wait until after
college to meet somebody or outside of
college to meet somebody or you can do
what I did and marry your high school
sweetheart
next question
hello Smokey Mike this is Julia your
number one fan girl
I really enjoyed your Purdue speech I
was lucky enough to go and unfortunately
my friend was the guy who was yelling at
you that aliens are demons so I'm sorry
if he annoyed you my question is what do
you think of natural Family Planning I
know that the Catholic Church supports
this and it's obviously much better than
contraception or abortion
but a lot of my friends who practice
natural Family Planning don't seem as
open to life as they ought to be as
Catholics so I was wondering your
thoughts on natural Family Planning
thanks
really great question I'm still forming
my thoughts on it actually for for the
non-catholics out there natural Family
Planning is
a method of
observing your one's menstrual cycle to
observe naturally and scientifically
when one is most likely to be fertile
and so it can be used to encourage
conception and it can be used to figure
out when you're not likely to conceive
and that's often how it's it's used
but it is wrong I've got my 1962 missile
that says that it's wrong it's a sin to
intentionally abstain
from the marital act on on a day so that
you don't have kids it would be wrong to
be closed off to life but there were
there was the principle of double effect
here one you you might have a health
condition that that suggests that you
know you would have a serious danger if
you were to become pregnant at a certain
time so that would seem to be a good use
of this it doesn't use any artificial
methods or establish the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human life which would you know which
would be a bad thing so
the the Catholic Church says that some
form of NFP is is fine and
they don't ask my opinion on that and
you know it's it's above my pay grade
but I I think your
trepidation with it is important to keep
in mind which is that if you were using
this as a way to be closed off to life
then you are probably abusing this uh
natural and scientific resource that's
available to you next question
hi Michael love the show I wanted to ask
for your opinion about a family
disagreement I'm 26 and married with a
nine month old my brother is 23 and
still living at home going to school
part-time but barely and doesn't have a
job he lived on his own for about six
months and didn't hold a job or go to
school for that time he recently begged
to move back home likely after not
enjoying paying rent anyway we had a
falling out recently after years of
inaccurate relationship but my brother
refuses to acknowledge or apologize for
any of his past mistakes including
threatening to sue me and threatening to
call the FBI on me for totally
Preposterous reasons our parents are
unhappy about our Tiff and tell me if I
don't apologize and smooth it over he
likely never will they likely see how
this will impact their ability to have
our son or future children to their home
and my son's first birthday is coming up
it seems they think I'm being the
unforgiving older sister from a Biblical
perspective I believe I can forgive him
but that restoration and Reconciliation
come from repentance which is what's
missing what would be your perspective
on how to approach this family drama
thanks oh brilliantly stated and you you
don't need me to help you understand
this you've got a very clear view
yourself and a good view sorry to hear
you going through that
you you want to be forgiving
and you want to apologize for anything
that you've done wrong it sounds like
your brother is a complete lunatic
and some people have lunatics in their
family so you could apologize for
something you did wrong
if you did anything wrong here
but you shouldn't apologize if you
didn't do anything wrong that would be
lying
now
what would I do if I wanted to keep the
peace and it seems like your family your
parents don't think he's moving out
anytime soon
what would I do if I wanted to keep the
peace I would probably
say hey bro you know if I did anything
wrong sorry I ate your
cookie that one time sorry I borrowed
your Walkman or I don't know really
dating myself with my references today
um and I would say you know we're going
to come over for my kids first birthday
party and uh you know that's just the
way it is so
look forward to seeing you pal and he
can whine and cry and complain about it
or do whatever he's obviously not a
stable person
um
but you you can't control that that's
totally out of your control and so and
if your parents say well we're not going
to let you come over because
your brother is a nut well you can't
control that either
all you can do is act in a way that is
charitable which I think you're doing
and forgiving which you said you will do
but also prudent you know and not
dishonest you don't want to you don't
want to apologize for something you
didn't do and you don't want to open
yourself up to an involvement in his
degeneracy and his his bizarre and
harmful behaviors
so I would be prudent about that too and
you know if your parents won't let you
over to the house because
there are new their new border is a
little crazy and I guess they've got to
come to your apartment or house for for
your kid's birthday next question
hello Michael Knowles this is JP ashborn
speaking
um
I'm gonna try and keep this quick and
keep it concise
um so here we go
so when I cast my eyes upon the world I
notice in my heart just seethes with
anger the good are killed and the wicked
live the innocent or punished and
prosecuted while the guilty gain even
more power and control
sin is publicly celebrated encouraged
and deemed as righteous while what is
truly righteous is shunned banished and
exiled from public life
this torrent of anger is wholly natural
to me and it comes you know regardless
of my choice
my question is as a fellow Christian
what is your advice on how I can
mitigate such natural feelings because
they're not good they don't feel good so
so thank you for everything you do God
bless
you got to look in the mirror
that's the problem because you're you're
seeing the world correctly but you're
not seeing yourself correctly
I suspect I suspect that you are not
perfect
maybe you are I don't know
but if you're anything like me you're
not perfect and so it's very easy to see
the sins of others and all the problems
of the world and
you know pull your hair out about it but
look at yourself in the mirror look at
your own infirmities I think what you're
struggling with is a little bit of Wrath
certainly but it's pride pride is the
queen of all sins and you think this is
outrageous and I don't deserve this and
I deserve better than this crappy world
and if only everyone were like me you
know but no you you look around you say
gosh look at how
look at what a jerk I am look at how
Fallen I am hmm
and the way we get the world is just a
bunch of me's running around and then
it's a Fallen World so you kind of look
around you say there before the grace of
God go live someone's really in a bad
place and then you you put your hope in
the life of the world to come
and you through acts of Charity and
Works of Mercy try to improve the world
around you
but I would look around this very Fallen
World and say how can I help
what can I do
and how can I stop contributing to all
the bad stuff going on that's what I
would I would do first
usually when people are dealing with
pride I say stop looking at the mirror
look out the window but with you with
this manifestation of Pride which is the
deadliest sin and which we all need to
guard against I would say stop looking
out the window start looking at the
mirror okay let's get to a question from
Ricardo Ricardo says hey Mike short but
so sweet not so sweet question
how do you answer someone that claims
gender and sex are separate Concepts
obviously the easy answer is to say
they've always been the same but that
doesn't seem to work anymore because
they'll claim times are changing thanks
for your input well
I think they are separate Concepts it's
true that the way the gender ideology
works
is that really over the last 50 60 years
they've diverged and the libs have used
this to deny biological reality there
was some precedent for this I believe
gender was used to refer to sex as a
synonym for sex as early as the 16th
century but gender expression certainly
is distinct from sex
just by definition
your sex is your biology derives from
your biology and then your gender
expression is your performance of that
and that's why they're effeminate men
and there are Butch
and that's all true
and what the libs conclude from this is
that if you wish for your gender
expression to be very different from
your sex then you should ignore your sex
and pursue your gender expression but I
don't see why that's the conclusion I
think it should be the opposite
conclusion you know your sex you know
that for sure and that sex is immutable
so if you have some fancy about your
gender expression that is outside of
normal limits of deviation then you
should rein that in because you have not
a right to deny the reality of your sex
you actually have an obligation to bring
your gender expression into line with
your sex
that's what I do give them the premise
yeah of course yeah there's tomboys
there's guys who are a little bit Faye
yeah sure
but your sex is real and unchangeable
your gender expression is quite
changeable obviously and so
when those run into conflict change the
thing that can actually be changed the
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it become a member and
use code noltskin wlas at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh